it's great to have back on the show
today nick majuli who is the coo at
ritholtz wealth management also founder
of of dollars and data a data focused
personal finance blog and also author of
the new book just keep buying proven
ways to save money and build your wealth
uh nick the the book is killing on
amazon it's crazy what's going on
i appreciate it yeah it's been a crazy
few days so far so you know one of the
questions i often get from my viewers is
are financial advisors a scam and what i
try to explain is at the individual
level the answer is no i mean sure there
are financial advisors whose practices
are scammy and there's financial
advisors that that are not but what i
say the scam is
is that the financial services industry
has sold the idea to people that basic
personal finance is really complicated
and you can't handle it yourself and
what you do in your book
is you explain in really clear terms the
most important you know eight to ten
principles about managing money and you
really explain that it's not as
complicated as maybe the industry wants
you to believe is that fair
yeah i think that's true at times i mean
obviously it depends on your situation
and i think that when financial planning
makes the most sense is the more complex
it gets especially with taxes so
usually i think for most people it
doesn't make sense to be paying a fee if
you don't have a lot of assets very
simple i mean unless you just want the
peace of mind and so that's what a lot
of people really that you know i work in
the wealth management industry full
disclosure of course a lot of people
come to us for us for the peace of mind
it's not necessarily like you know it's
not that they couldn't do it themselves
a lot of times there's like i don't want
to do it i'm going to spend my time
doing something more valuable and i
think that's why for a lot of people
it's worth
the price they pay one of the things
that
you talk about in the book and you back
it up with data is kind of the futility
of this idea of
when should i be investing how when is
the right time to sort of get in and to
get out and this is something i've
talked to my audience about a lot and
every time that the markets are shaky
and we saw this in march of 2020 at the
start of the pandemic we've seen it over
the last two months
so many people you look at twitter you
look at reddit you look at all these
different places they're saying i'm
gonna give it five more days or i'm
gonna wait or this isn't exactly the
right time statistic aside from anyone's
opinions about their ability to predict
the future which is not very good humans
are not particularly good at that
lay out the statistical case for why it
doesn't really make sense to be doing
that
yeah so if you're trying to wait so
waiting to like buy a dip is one thing
and then just waiting at all is usually
a bad idea and the reason why is because
most of the time markets you know
generally increase over time of course
there's gonna be cases where markets
crash and things like that but you know
if you're going to compare someone who's
trying to even if you know i use in the
book chapter 14 it's called even god
couldn't beat dollar cost averaging and
i basically say i'm going to tell you
when the dips are and you're going to
save cash and buy those dips like the
lowest point between two all-time highs
like on a monthly basis and that
strategy actually underperforms someone
who's just buys every month like 80 of
the time and the reason why is because
by the time you wait for that big dip by
the time it happens that price that dip
price is higher than what you could have
bought originally right so you're like
you're always ending up buying at a
higher price and so there's always gonna
be reasons to sell like you can all you
always can you know psych yourself out
about this stuff and don't get me wrong
sometimes people are gonna move to cash
and they're gonna be right once in a
while right and they're gonna be right
in the short run but i think the
behavioral reason why you shouldn't do
it is you're going to be wrong in the
long run right if imagine every time you
know imagine and you know after 2009
you're like wow this i'm going to stay
out of the market for a while 2010 2011
you stay out you're like wow look i'm
smart or whatever markets are covered a
little bit but then you stay out for the
next five ten years and you miss one of
the biggest bull markets in history
right and that's what's happened there's
been people saying the stock market's
been overvalued since 2012 2013 the
market's been on an upward tear since so
one day they'll be right but they're
going to be wrong most of the time and
that's the issue here the the other
concern i would have with such a
strategy and many of my friends do this
stuff and i tell them i think you're i
think you're wasting your time is that
i'm big on systematizing what i'm trying
to do with my finances and even if you
believe that you would be really good at
figuring out okay we've hit the bottom
now is the time to start buying again
it's not a systematic approach and the
systematic approach has the advantages
number one of being in my mind far less
stressful and anxiety causing number two
if you continue your investment plan on
the way down
you're actually getting more value for
your money in the sense that a hundred
dollars buys you more shares when the
market is down than when the market is
up
and thirdly and correct me if i'm wrong
you're continuing to accumulate
dividends during that time and uh
somebody who is just waiting is is not
going to be doing that so it seems that
the systematic aspect has both
psychological and financial benefits
yeah i completely agree and so the whole
like my argument is like you know do
something better with your time right
like like david i think you're probably
better suited to be you know hosting a
youtube show and talking about this then
spending you know five ten hours a week
looking at your investments right if you
think about the return you're gonna get
on your personal human capital and for
someone else that may be like i'm a
photography person like maybe you should
do more photo shoots or someone you know
is a writer and so they should write
more blog posts whatever it is whatever
you do like i bet there's some higher
value activity you have than going and
investing and doing that stuff with your
money especially if you don't have a lot
of money invested if you have ten
thousand dollars invested right let's
say you can you know increase your
returns by you know let's say
10 right that's a thousand bucks unless
you spend 10 hours a week doing that
over the course of a year right so let's
say 10 times you know 50 500 you spend
500 hours to make a thousand dollars
like think about that like it's so silly
like you would no you should you should
literally just get a part-time job you'd
make way more money right so it's one of
those things when you start thinking
about the math on it you're like wow my
hourly wage of doing this doesn't make
any sense you know if you have 10
million dollars that's a little
different but you know most of us don't
so
when it comes to uh debt there's there's
some interesting parts of the book about
you talk about mortgages uh you talk
about debt in different ways
debt is very
polarizing and i don't mean necessarily
politically polarizing i'm not talking
about the national debt i'm talking
about personal debt people's decisions
about credit cards as well as people's
decisions about mortgages and very
commonly you'll you'll hear strategies
espoused i if i understand correctly uh
christian financial guy dave ramsey
talks about starting um with i don't
remember if it's the smallest debt or
the highest interest debt first
everybody has some algorithm that they
will sometimes apply
what's often missing from those
conversations are the sort of
psychological impacts of having the debt
and so when people sometimes have called
i guess they call me because my
background was in financial planning
although i haven't been in that space
for 15 years they'll say should one pay
off a mortgage if you have the cash to
do it and you can run the numbers
calculating what's your mortgage
interest deduction and what's the
interest rate you can do all that
but at the end of the day there's an
intangible which is like psychologically
what is having the debt do for your
day-to-day and that can be much harder
to kind of wrap our minds around can it
not
yeah i think some of the the data on
that's interesting so the only debt that
didn't have any sort of psychological
impact at least on average across the
population was
mortgage debt that's the only every
other debt messes with people if you
have credit card debt that's usually
stressful if you have other type medical
debt whatever that usually affects
people's psyche they found that mortgage
debt generally doesn't affect people
however there is a subset of the
population that doesn't feel comfortable
with any debt and that's fine so you're
not going to want to hold debt at all so
even those people like i know people
very smart in the financial space and
they've paid off their homes despite the
fact that they had like a three percent
interest rate you know and they did that
because they just want the peace of mind
and so for some people peace of mind is
going to be better than all that other
stuff and so just you have to think
about that you know when you're making
these types of financial decisions so
there's nothing wrong with it but just
you kind of have to know yourself right
there's almost a
story as old as time this is like a
philosophical point that's been around
for thousands of years like know thyself
right like so once you know kind of what
you like and don't like that's how you
can make better decisions with your
money when it comes to timing and real
estate
uh
are the principles different than when
it comes to timing the stock market in
the sense of if you have a need for
housing you can choose to buy or you can
choose to rent and very often rents will
reflect
the cost to whoever ultimately owns the
property in which you're going to live
so there's there's a correlation there
although it may not be perfect all of
the time
um sometimes people who already own a
place say well i'd like to move but i
want to wait
until the property is worth more but
then in
in all likelihood the property you're
looking to buy will also have uh
increased in value unless you've got
maybe some market arbitrage because
you're looking to move or something like
that how does the timing piece affect
the purchase of property
so yeah i think because like every so if
you're saying like oh i'm going to buy
like a reit right you're going to put
money into like a reit fund that has
you're owning a broad basket of you know
commercial properties or whatever
commercial and residential properties
across the us i think timing's not going
to matter that much i mean obviously
there will be ebbs and flows in the
market overall however when you're
buying an individual property timing
matters a lot because you can
the corollary in the stock market is
like going from buying the s p 500 index
fund to just buying apple you're buying
a single buying one individual property
is like buying a single stock right so
you have single stock risk in your
individual home so like of course time
is going to matter in the sense that
there's a lot more risk when you buy an
individual stock or an individual
property so like
there's no real great way around that
right you're you're going to have to
take that individual stock risk so to
speak with that individual property and
so like yes timing's going to matter and
you're right that like other properties
will go up in value too so
you just got to figure out like hey is
this the right time for me and don't try
to look at it as an investment i think
when you buy a home it needs to be
something more for your personal life
societal reasons we're doing it maybe
your personal life stable now you have a
few kids or whatever and you know like
hey this is the neighborhood i want to
be in this is everything i want and you
just move and i think if you think about
it as an investment it's going to be
really tough for you because your home
should not be i mean it can be an
investment but you can't eat the equity
your home price could double you can't
do anything about that especially if you
move to another home you end up selling
at home buying another one what what did
you actually earn nothing right if all
the prices move so you can't eat your
equity unfortunately until you do some
sort of arbitrage like you said like the
californians moving to idaho and et
cetera right so
so we've talked about stocks we've
talked about real estate uh
cryptocurrency cryptocurrency um there
are so many opinions many of them
informed many of them not informed many
of them misinformed on cryptocurrency
my view on cryptocurrency has been i
want some upside exposure there and so
years and years ago as we've talked
about before i got some bitcoin and some
ethereum
um and i kind of determined given its
volatility what's the right asset
allocation for me and for me it's about
three percent of my total assets and so
if it goes to zero i lose three percent
of my total assets at this point
it has grown so much and i've sold
pieces of it that even if it went to
zero i come out ahead but the point is
i'm thinking of the volatility
in determining what is my right exposure
in terms of asset allocation is this the
right approach when you are dealing with
a relatively new and volatile asset
yes i completely agree with that i
actually did a i did some analysis and i
found like the optimal portfolio had
like two percent bitcoin and that's
basically what my crypto allocation has
been so three two percent some go up to
five you know i think that's very
prudent i don't think there's much to
add i think you almost had a perfect
answer there so well let me let's so
let's then go in this direction there
seems to be
a sort of moral
assessment done with crypto that isn't
always done with stock holdings which i
find interesting like for example
when i hold a total stock market index
fund
there are absolutely companies in there
that are probably not great companies
there's statistically speaking there's
companies in there that are
uh committing fraud of securities fraud
of some kind there's the full kind of
gamut
but i don't find myself emotionally tied
to that in the way that sometimes people
make very emotional reactions to bitcoin
or ethereum what do you think it is that
causes some at least to view these
things so differently
i think there's just so much fanaticism
on both sides so i think like the pro
crypto people are so pro crypto they can
only see that way and most of them i
think have like a very very large
percentage of their assets encrypted
it's gone up a lot
so they are going to be guys and there's
people on the other side who weren't in
on it and i think it's a big scam and
it's worthless and all the stuff and
they're going to be biased in their own
ways and i think it's really tough to
have a balanced view on this because
you're going to bring some bias in i'm
saying i have so i own some crypto i
think i'm trying to do in a prudent way
but you know i'm not perfect on it but
i'm probably slightly biased against it
only because it's not income producing
and so i kind of talk about that in the
book like income producing assets should
be the bulk of your wealth which is like
stocks bonds real estate things that
actually you know actually produce
income now bonds obviously have done
terribly recently but for most of
history they've been decent so you know
there's there's a lot of talk about
reducing bond allocation so and then i
think makes sense
last thing i want to talk about in terms
of all the signals that people can pay
attention to if you have a systematic
plan an asset allocation and you just do
that every month it seems to me that
there would be very little financial
news that you would really need to pay
attention to in terms of like what's
actionable so let me just throw a few
things out there and you tell me whether
these things even really matter to the
average investor more and more articles
now talk about
when the yield curve inverts it signals
a coming recession that's like one that
that is out there and it's very popular
or when the cape ratio goes above or
below a certain place it signals that
okay so all these different things
aside from whether these are accurate
does it really matter to the average
investor if you have a systematic plan
because it's i'm not seeing how you
would change your behavior even if some
of these metrics were accurate
predictors
well so they actually the yield current
version is a pretty decent predictor of
recession and so if you actually look at
the data after an inversion like yes
stock returns are lower the problem is
where like what are your options you're
like oh just move to bonds well guess
what bonds underperform stocks even
after yield curve inversion so like you
don't really have a choice you just kind
of have to like deal with a terrible
situation and that's probably what at
some point you know assuming history
repeats itself it doesn't always like
the august 29 in version didn't lead to
recession
i mean people will say oh there was a
recession covid you know 2020 but i'm
going to argue that the the current
version 2019 was not predicting the
covid you know let's be honest here i
agree with this then so yeah so you see
my point my point is though
these things happen and they are
predictive of lower returns even like
higher cape is predictive lower returns
or future returns i agree with that the
problem is what are your options what
are you going to do you can try and move
to cash in time but
the cape's been at 30 since 2017. the
market's doubled since then like what
you're gonna be sitting there sitting in
cash while the market's doubled and
you're just now right now you're getting
eight percent inflation you're done so
like you kind of have to just go on this
wild ride and there's no real options
you have you know
uh the book is just keep buying proven
ways to save money and build your wealth
the book is listed at davidpakman.com
finance when you can see my other
finance books recommendations we've been
speaking with the book's author nick
majuli nick always great speaking with
you thanks
thanks dave appreciate it